hey guys Alexa ray here with a gamespot
news update if you were thinking that no
man's sky would full of stealth released
this week nope hello games the developer
of the highly anticipated space
exploration game for playstation 4 and
pc has spoken out to shut down any
rumors that the game would be releasing
this week Shaun Murray the game's
director said I heard that rumor that no
man sky is stealth releasing on October
27 it is false online rumors suggested
that no man's sky would be released as
part of a surprise announcement during
Sony's press conference at Paris games
week Sony's Paris games week briefing is
slated for tomorrow at ten a.m. pacific
it's possible that no man's sky could be
featured at the show but Murray will not
be in Paris this week sony has teased
that they have an amazing show planned a
release date for no man's sky has not
been announced but hello games has
confirmed that the ps4 and PC editions
will launch on the same day recently the
game appeared on The Late Show with
Stephen Colbert the comedian appeared to
be very much in awe by the size and
scope of no man's sky let's be honest
that rumor was way too good to be true
check back with GameSpot tomorrow for
the latest on Paris games week